Alex Meyer wants my job. He's 16, and he wants my job. But nobody is going to give him my job, or really any job in radio. And so last year he decided to create his own radio show as a high school freshman in Seattle. And he did it with the kind of devotion and attention to detail of a true believer. It's kind of an amazing show actually, starting with the opening, which he lifted from one of his radio heroes, Tom Leykis, who does a syndicated show out of Los Angeles.
亚历克斯·梅耶想要我的工作。他16岁，他想要我的工作。但没人会把我的工作给他，或者说，在广播行业，没人会给他任何工作。所以去年，身为西雅图高中一年级学生的他，决定创办自己的广播节目。他带着那种真正信徒般的虔诚和对细节的关注去做了这件事。实际上，这个节目相当令人惊叹，尤其是开场，他直接沿用了他的一位广播偶像——汤姆·莱基斯，那位在洛杉矶主持联合广播节目的播音员。
I was pretty much ripping off Leykis, because at the top of every hour he plays Metallica, "Enter Sandman." And he has this big thing. They're all saying, "Live from Los Angeles, it's the Tom Leykis Show." And he's like "Thank you for tuning into the Tom Leykis show. It's not hosted by a right wing wacko, a convicted felon. No, I'm your host." Blah, blah, blah, blah. And gives out the numbers and everything. So I was like, I want something like that.
我基本上是剽窃莱基斯的，因为他每个整点都会播放Metallica乐队的《Enter Sandman》。他还有个标志性的开场白，他们都在说：“这是洛杉矶直播的汤姆·莱基斯秀。”他说：“感谢收听汤姆·莱基斯秀。主持人不是什么右翼怪胎或刑满释放犯。不，我是你们的主持人。”等等，等等。然后报出电话号码之类的。所以我当时就想，我也要那种感觉。
Yeah that sounds good.
是的，听起来不错。
I want my big thing. "Hey everybody. It's The Alex Meyer Show. 1-800-421-ALEX, toll-free. Yeah that's free. 1-800-421-2539--" Actually, if you call that number, it's AT&T. And I think they ask you if you want it in Spanish. In Seattle, a lot of the radio station numbers start with 421. That's something I noticed. And put 421, put ALEX, 1-800. Oh, sounds good.
我要有自己的标志性开场。“大家好，这是亚历克斯·梅耶秀。1-800-421-ALEX，免费电话。是的，免费的。1-800-421-2539——”其实如果你拨打那个号码，那是AT&T的电话。我想他们会问你是否需要西班牙语服务。在西雅图，很多广播电台的电话号码都是以421开头的。这是我注意到的。加上421，加上ALEX，1-800。噢，听起来不错。
Now sometimes you have your friend Matt come on and--
现在有时你会让你的朋友马特上节目，然后——
Yeah, my quote, "producer." I gave him that title, because I needed a producer character to pretty much yell at. Because you hear that a lot on the radio here, dysfunctional radio shows. So I figured, wow. He's pretty much just a character.
是的，我所谓的“制作人”。我给了他这个头衔，因为我需要一个制作人角色来让我对他大吼大叫。因为你在收音机里经常听到那种功能失调的广播节目。所以我心想，哇，他基本上只是个角色。
"Well we have Matt the producer here to talk to you about this actually. This is Matt's area of expertise. It's something that happened to him. His ex-girlfriend pretty much wanted him for the dance. It almost seems like--
“好吧，关于这一点，我们请来了制作人马特和大家谈谈。这是马特的专业领域。这是发生在他身上的事。他的前女友基本上是为了舞会才找他的。这看起来好像——”
That's what it seems like.
看起来确实是这样。
She used him for the dance.
她利用他参加了舞会。
That's what it seems like.
看起来确实是这样。
And I'll tell you something. A while ago, she asked me to the next dance.
跟你说件事。不久前，她邀请我参加下一场舞会。
Wow.
哇。
And see, I never really wanted to go with her. First I told her I was building houses for poor people in Mexico, and therefore would not be able to make it.
你看，我从来没想过和她一起去。起初我告诉她我正在墨西哥为穷人盖房子，所以没法参加。
What's remarkable is that even though Alex is making the show in his room on his dad's discarded cassette recorder, and even though the show never actually broadcasts anywhere, it sounds like a real commercial radio talk show. The pacing, the fact that Alex is closer to the mic than any of his guests so he sounds clearer and louder. He has phone callers, though of course, since he's not broadcasting, Alex plays those himself.
值得注意的是，尽管亚历克斯是在他的房间里用他父亲扔掉的盒式录音机制作这个节目，而且这个节目实际上从未在任何地方播出过，但它听起来就像真正的商业谈话电台节目。节奏感，还有亚历克斯比他任何嘉宾都更靠近麦克风，所以他的声音听起来更清晰、更大声。他有电话听众，当然，因为他没有播出，所以这些电话都是亚历克斯自己假装的。
And I have Dan from Eugene.
现在我有来自尤金的丹。
Dan is an irritating character.
丹是一个让人讨厌的角色。
Yeah, I had to have the guy who hated me. And he's that character.
是的，我必须得有个讨厌我的人。他就是那个角色。
Yeah.
是的。
So every time he calls, I'm, Alex, I hate your show. You suck. This is Dan from Eugene.
所以每次他打来电话，我就会说，亚历克斯，我讨厌你的节目。你烂透了。我是来自尤金的丹。
I love how part of the formula of having a fantasy radio show is that you have a fantasy person who hates your guts.
我喜欢这种奇幻广播节目的套路，就是你得有一个虚构的人物来恨之入骨。
Well, it's kind of fun being someone that hates you though. It is kind of fun.
嗯，做一个恨你的人其实挺有趣的。真的挺有趣的。
To make it sound as real as possible, Alex uses real commercials that he tapes off the radio. Sometimes he and Matt pretend to have a seven second delay, like Howard Stern and the other big shows use. And someone has said a bad word, so what you hear is this sudden gap and jump in content, though of course, it's just a cassette in his bedroom. It's not a real broadcast. And like any modern ambitious talk show host, there are right wing rants. That's just part of the formula.
为了让节目听起来尽可能真实，亚历克斯使用了他从广播里录下来的真实广告。有时他和马特会假装有七秒的延迟，就像霍华德·斯特恩和其他大节目那样。如果有人说了脏话，你听到的就是内容突然的中断和跳跃，当然，这只是他卧室里的磁带。这并不是真正的广播。而且像任何有抱负的现代谈话节目主持人一样，节目里也有右翼的咆哮。这只是套路的一部分。
You know what makes no sense at all.
你知道什么是最没道理的吗。
A dollar bill--
一张一美元纸币——
For me to pass high school, according to the state, I need to learn Spanish. Yet--
对我来说，要通过高中，根据州的规定，我必须学习西班牙语。然而——
Or any foreign language.
或者任何外语。
Wait, wait. But yet, foreigners working in 7-Elevens don't have to know a god damn word of English.
等等，等等。然而，在7-Eleven工作的外国人根本不需要会说哪怕一个英语单词。
No they don't.
是的，他们不需要。
What sense does that make? For me to live in this country, I have to learn a foreign language. They don't have to learn anything.
这有什么道理？为了住在这个国家，我必须学习一门外语。他们却什么都不用学。
I wondered if you're more like a real radio personality or shock jock, where that's a thought that, actually, you only half believe that. But your views aren't quite as extreme as you're saying in the recording.
我很好奇，你更像是一个真正的广播个性和“震惊电台”主持人吗？那种想法其实你只信了一半，但你的观点并不像你在录音里说得那么极端。
Yeah pretty much. I mean it's more of an shtick thing, I guess.
是的，差不多。我的意思是，那更多是一种噱头，我想。
Alex distributes his show by copying it onto CDs for friends at school. Big ratings for him, he says, are when he gets an audience of six, six people. But frankly, having people listen doesn't seem to be the important part of it to him. He's in training. No one seems to be interested giving a 16 year old a job in radio or a place to learn. So he created his own place where he's learning, honing his skills, preparing for the future, which brings me to the subject of today's radio show.
亚历克斯通过为学校的朋友复制CD来传播他的节目。他说，当他有六个听众时，那就是极高的收视率了。但坦率地说，有没有人听对他来说似乎并不重要。他正在受训。似乎没人有兴趣给一个16岁的孩子一份广播工作或一个学习的地方。所以他创造了自己的天地，在那里他进行学习，磨练技能，为未来做准备，这让我引出了今天广播节目的主题。
Today on our program, we bring you three stories of people who take on unlikely tasks, put themselves in charge in very unpromising circumstances. And we see what happens to them as a result. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. Act One of today's show, It's Not Just the Aces That Are Wild. In that act, David Sedaris tells the story of how as a teenager he was scared of certain people until he made them scared of him.
今天在我们的节目中，我们为您带来三个关于人们承担不可能的任务，在极不乐观的情况下掌舵的故事。我们来看看结果如何。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《这就是美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。今天节目的第一幕，“不仅仅是王牌大显身手”。在这一幕中，大卫·塞达里斯讲述了他十几岁时如何害怕某些人，直到他让他们反过来害怕他。
Act Two, Playing Clinton in the Bush Leagues, in which we bring you the story of a politician with tons of charisma, full of promise, who goes through the fastest rise and fall we have ever heard of in politics. Act Three, You Talking to Me? Yes, we all know we Americans declared ourselves the rulers of Iraq for now. So why is one of the most popular rumors in the country that Saddam Hussein is not only alive, but living in the White House? Stay with us.
第二幕，“在低级别联赛中扮演克林顿”，我们为你讲述一个极具魅力、前途无量的政客的故事，他经历了我们所听过的政治领域中最快的起起落落。第三幕，“你在跟我说话吗？”是的，我们都知道，美国人现在宣布自己是伊拉克的统治者。那么，为什么国内最流行的谣言之一是萨达姆·侯赛因不仅活着，而且住在白宫里呢？请继续收听。
And let's get right to it with Act One. Here's writer David Sedaris, recorded in front of a live audience in Boston.
让我们直接进入第一幕。这里是作家大卫·塞达里斯，录制于波士顿的现场观众面前。
My parents were not the type of people who went to bed at a regular hour. Sleep overtook them, but neither the time nor the idea of a mattress seemed very important. My father favored a chair in the basement, but my mother was apt to lie down anywhere, waking with carpet burns on her face or the pattern of the sofa embossed into the soft flesh of her upper arms. It was sort of embarrassing. She might sleep for eight hours a day. But they were never consecutive hours, and they involved no separate outfit.
我的父母不是那种会在固定时间上床睡觉的人。睡意会袭向他们，但睡眠时间和床垫对他们来说似乎都不怎么重要。我父亲喜欢地下室的一把椅子，但我母亲随时随地都能躺下，醒来时脸上带着地毯的压痕，或是沙发的花纹印在她上臂柔软的皮肤上。那有点尴尬。她每天可能会睡八个小时。但那从来不是连续的时间，而且也不需要什么特别的打扮。
For Christmas, we would give her nightgowns, hoping she might take the hint. They're for bedtime, we'd say. Then she'd look at us strangely as if, like the moment of one's death, the occasion of sleep was too incalculable for any real preparation.
圣诞节时，我们会送她睡袍，希望她能领会暗示。我们会说，这是睡觉用的。然后她会奇怪地看着我们，仿佛睡眠的场合就像人死亡的时刻一样，过于难以预料，以至于无法做任何真正的准备。
The upswing to being raised by what were essentially a pair of house cats was that we never had any enforced bedtime. We were the family that never shut down, the family whose TV was so hot we needed an oven mitt in order to change the channels. Every night was basically a slumber party. So when the real thing came along, my sisters and I failed to show much of an interest.
被一对本质上是家猫的父母抚养长大的好处是，我们从没有强制的就寝时间。我们是一个从不“关机”的家庭，我们家的电视热得我们需要用烤箱手套才能换台。每个夜晚基本上都是睡衣派对。所以当真正的睡衣派对到来时，我和我的姐妹们并没有表现出太大的兴趣。
The first one I attended was held by a neighbor named Walt Winters. Like myself, Walt was in the sixth grade. Unlike myself, he was gregarious and athletic, which meant basically that we had absolutely nothing in common. "But why would he include me?" I asked my mother. "I hardly know the guy." She did not say that Walt's mother had made him invite me, but on watching her turn away, I knew that this was the only likely explanation. "Oh go," she said, "it'll be fun."
我参加的第一个派对是由一位叫沃尔特·温特斯的邻居举办的。和我一样，沃尔特也在上六年级。不像我，他性格开朗且热爱运动，这意味着我们完全没有共同点。“但他为什么要邀请我？”我问母亲。“我几乎不认识他。”她没说沃尔特是因为他母亲逼他才邀请我的，但看着她转身的样子，我知道这才是唯一可能的解释。“哦，去吧，”她说，“会很有趣的。”
There were four styles of houses on our street, and while Walt's was different from my own, I was familiar with the layout. The slumber party took place in what the Methodists called the family room, the Catholics used as an extra bedroom, and the neighborhood's only Jews had turned into a combination dark room and fallout shelter. Walt's family was Methodist, and so the room's focal point was a large black and white television. Family photos hung on the wall alongside pictures of the various athletes Mr. Winters had successfully pestered for autographs.
我们街上有四种户型的房子，虽然沃尔特的房子和我自己的不同，但我对布局很熟悉。睡衣派对是在卫理公会教徒称之为“家庭活动室”的地方举行的，天主教徒用它做额外的卧室，而邻里唯一的犹太人则把它变成了一个暗室和防空洞的结合体。沃尔特的家人是卫理公会教徒，所以房间的焦点是一台巨大的黑白电视。墙上挂着家庭照片，旁边还有温特斯先生从各种运动员那里厚着脸皮要来的签名照。
I admired them to the best of my ability but was more interested in the wedding portrait displayed above the sofa. Arm in arm with her uniformed husband, Walt's mother looked deliriously, almost frighteningly happy. The bulging eyes and fierce, gummy smile. It was an expression bordering on hysteria, and the intervening years had done nothing to dampen it. On passing Mrs. Winters waving gaily from her front yard, my mother would whisper, "What is she on?" I thought she was being too hard on her, but after 10 minutes in the woman's home, I understood exactly what my mother was talking about.
我尽我所能地赞美它们，但我对沙发上方展示的结婚照更感兴趣。沃尔特的母亲挽着穿制服的丈夫，看起来神魂颠倒，几乎令人恐惧地幸福。那凸出的眼睛和凶狠的、露着牙龈的笑容。那是一种近乎歇斯底里的表情，随后的几年里，这种表情从未减弱过。当看到温特斯太太在院子里欢快地挥手时，我母亲会低声说：“她到底吃了什么？”我觉得她对他太苛刻了，但在那个女人的家里待了10分钟后，我完全明白了我母亲在说什么。
"Pizza's here," she chimed when the delivery man came to the door. "Oh boys, how about some piping hot pizza?" I thought it was funny that anyone would use the words piping hot. But it wasn't the kind of thing I felt I could actually laugh at. Neither could I laugh at Mr. Winters' pathetic imitation of an Italian waiter. "Mamma Mia, who want another slice of the pizza?"
“披萨到了，”当送货员到门口时，她欢快地说道。“噢，孩子们，来点热气腾腾的披萨怎么样？”我觉得一个人用“热气腾腾”这个词很有趣。但我并不觉得那是我能真正笑出来的东西。我也无法对温特斯先生那蹩脚的意大利侍者模仿秀发笑。“妈妈咪呀，谁还想再来一片披萨？”
I had the idea that adults were supposed to make themselves scarce at slumber parties. But Walt's parents were all over the place, initiating games, offering snacks and refills. When the midnight horror movie came on, Walt's mother crept into the bathroom, leaving a ketchup-spattered knife beside the sink. An hour passed, and when none of us had yet discovered it, she started dropping little hints. "Doesn't anyone want to wash their hands?" she asked. "Will whoever is closest to the door go check and see if I left fresh towels in the bathroom?" You just wanted to cry for people like her.
我的印象是，成年人在睡衣派对上应该离得远远的。但沃尔特的父母到处都是，发起游戏，提供零食和续杯。当午夜恐怖电影开始时，沃尔特的母亲溜进洗手间，在洗手池旁留下了一把沾着番茄酱的刀。一个小时过去了，当我们还没人发现它时，她开始给出小小的暗示。“没人想洗手吗？”她问。“最靠近门的那个人去检查一下我是否在洗手间留了干净的毛巾好吗？”你只会为她这样的人感到想哭。
As corny as they were, I was sorry when the movie ended and Mr. And Mrs. Winters stood to leave. It was only 2:00 AM, but clearly they were done in. "I just don't know how you boys can do it," Walt's mother said, yawning into the sleeve of her bathrobe. "I haven't been up this late since Lauren came into the world. Lauren was Walt's sister, who was born premature and had lived for less than two days.
虽然它们很俗气，但当电影结束，温特斯夫妇起身离开时，我还是感到遗憾。才凌晨2点，但显然他们已经累坏了。“我真不知道你们这些小伙子是怎么做到的，”沃尔特母亲打着哈欠，对着浴袍袖子说，“我自从劳伦出生以来就没熬过这么晚。”劳伦是沃尔特的妹妹，早产，只活了不到两天。
This had happened before the Winters moved onto our street, but it wasn't any kind of a secret. And you weren't supposed to flinch upon hearing the girl's name. The baby had died too early to pose for photographs, but still she was regarded as a full fledged member of the family. She had a Christmas stocking the size of a mitten. And they even threw her an annual birthday party, a fact my mother found especially creepy. "Let's hope they don't invite us," she said. "I mean Jesus, how do you shop for a dead baby?"
这发生在温特斯一家搬到我们街上之前，但这并不是什么秘密。你被要求在听到这个女孩的名字时不能畏缩。那个婴儿死得太早，还没来得及拍照，但她仍然被视为家庭的正式成员。她有一个手套大小的圣诞袜。他们甚至每年都会为她举办生日派对，我母亲觉得这一点尤其令人毛骨悚然。“希望他们别邀请我们，”她说，“我的意思是，天哪，你怎么给一个死婴买礼物？”
I guessed it was the fear of another premature birth that kept Mrs. Winters from trying again, which was sad, as you got the sense she really wanted a lively household. You got the sense she had an idea of a lively household, and that the slumber party and the ketchup-covered knife were all a part of that idea. While in her presence, we had played along. But once she said good night, I understood that all bets were off. She and her husband lumbered up the stairs. And when Walt felt certain they were asleep, he pounced on Dale Gummerson, shouting "Titty twister!" Brad Clancy joined in, and when they had finished, Dale raised his shirt, revealing nipples as crimped and ruddy as the pepperoni slices littering the forsaken pizza box.
我猜正是对另一次早产的恐惧让温特斯太太没再尝试生育，这很令人难过，因为你能感觉到她真的很想要一个热闹的家庭。你能感觉到她对热闹家庭有个概念，而睡衣派对和沾着番茄酱的刀都是那个概念的一部分。在她在场时，我们配合着表演。但当她道过晚安后，我知道一切都不一样了。她和丈夫笨重地走上楼梯。当沃尔特确定他们睡着后，他猛扑向戴尔·古默森，大喊：“乳头扭转！”布拉德·克兰西也加入了，当他们完成后，戴尔掀起衬衫，露出的乳头就像撒在废弃披萨盒上的意大利辣香肠片一样皱巴巴、红彤彤的。
"Oh my God," I said, realizing too late that this made me sound like a girl. The appropriate response was to laugh at Dale's misfortune, not to flutter your hands in front of your face, screeching, "What have they done to your poor nipples? Shouldn't we put some ice on them?"
“噢，天哪，”我说，意识到太晚了，这让我听起来像个女孩。适当的反应应该是嘲笑戴尔的倒霉，而不是在脸前扇动手，尖叫着：“他们对你可怜的乳头做了什么？我们不该放点冰块上去吗？”
Walt picked up on this immediately. "Did you just say you wanted to put ice on Dale's nipples?" "Well not me personally," I said. "I meant, you know, generally, as a group. Or Dale could do it himself if he felt like it."
沃尔特立刻抓住了这一点。“你刚才说你想给戴尔的乳头放点冰块？”“好吧，不是我个人，”我说，“我的意思是，你知道，作为一个群体来说。或者如果戴尔愿意，他可以自己放。”
Walt's eyes wandered from my face to my chest. And then the entire slumber party was upon me. My shirt was raised, a hand was clamped over my mouth, and Walt latched on to my nipples, twisting them back and forth as if they were a set of particularly stubborn lug nuts. "Now who needs ice?" he said. "Now who thinks he's a god damn school nurse?"
沃尔特的目光从我的脸移到我的胸部。接着整个睡衣派对的人都冲向了我。我的衬衫被掀起，一只手捂住我的嘴，沃尔特紧紧抓住我的乳头，来回扭动，就像它们是一组特别难搞的螺母。“现在谁需要冰块？”他说，“现在谁以为自己是该死的校医？”
I'd once felt sorry for Walt, but now, my eyes watering in pain, I understood that little Lauren was smart to have cut out early.
我曾经为沃尔特感到遗憾，但现在，我疼得眼泪直流，我明白小劳伦早点离开是明智的。
When eventually I was freed, I went upstairs and stood at the kitchen window, my arms folded lightly against my chest. My house was located in a ravine. You couldn't see it from the street, but still I could make out the glow of light spilling from the top of our driveway. It was tempting, but were I to leave now, I'd never hear the end of it. The baby cried. The baby had to go home. Life at school would be unbearable.
当我最终获释后，我走到楼上，站在厨房窗前，双臂轻轻交叠在胸前。我家位于山谷中。从街上看不见它，但我仍能分辨出从我家车道顶端透出的灯光。这很诱人，但如果我现在离开，我将永远听不到尽头。婴儿哭了。婴儿必须回家。学校的生活将变得无法忍受。
And so I left the window and returned to the basement where Walt was shuffling cards against the coffee table. "Just in time," he said. "Have a seat." I lowered myself to the floor and reached for a magazine. "I'm not really much for games. So if it's OK with you, I think I'll just watch." "Watch hell," Walt said. "This is strip poker. What kind of a homo wants to sit around and watch four guys get naked?"
于是我离开窗户回到地下室，沃尔特正在咖啡桌上洗牌。“来得正好，”他说，“坐下。”我坐到地板上，伸手拿过一本杂志。“我对游戏不太感兴趣。所以如果你们不介意，我想我只是看看。”“看个屁，”沃尔特说，“这是脱衣扑克。有哪个同性恋想坐在这里看四个家伙脱光衣服？”
The logic of this was lost on me. "Well won't we all sort of be watching?" "Looking maybe, but not watching," Walt said. "There's a difference." Again, I had no idea what he was talking about. Walt made a twisting motion with his fingers, and I took my place at the table, praying for a gas leak or an electrical fire, anything to save me from the catastrophe of strip poker. To the rest of the group, a naked boy was like a lamp or an extension cord, something so familiar and uninteresting it faded into the background. But for me it was different. A naked boy was what I desired more than anything on earth. And when you were both watching and desiring, things came up, one thing, in particular, that was bound to stand out and ruin your life forever.
我完全没听懂这其中的逻辑。“好吧，难道我们不都是在看吗？”“可能是在看，但不是在‘观看’，”沃尔特说，“这有区别。”再一次，我不知道他在说什么。沃尔特用手指做了个扭转动作，我在桌边坐下，祈祷发生煤气泄漏或电气火灾，任何能让我从脱衣扑克的灾难中解救出来的东西。对于其他人来说，一个裸体男孩就像一盏灯或一根延长线，熟悉且毫无趣味，以至于它会淡入背景。但对我来说不同。一个裸体男孩是我在地球上最渴望的东西。当你既在观看又在渴望时，事情就会发生，特别是某样东西，注定会突显出来并永远毁了你的生活。
"I hate to tell you," I said, "but it's against my religion to play poker." "Yeah right," Walt said. "What are you Baptists?" "Greek Orthodox." "Well then that's a load of crap, because the Greeks invented cards," Walt said. "Actually, I think it was the Egyptians." This from Scott, who was quickly identifying himself as the smart one. "Greeks, Egyptians, they're all the same thing," Walt said. "Anyway, what your pooh-bah doesn't know won't hurt him. So shut the hell up and play."
“我不想告诉你，”我说，“但玩扑克违背了我的宗教信仰。”“是啊，真的，”沃尔特说，“你们是浸信会吗？”“希腊正教。”“那简直是一派胡言，因为扑克牌是希腊人发明的，”沃尔特说。“其实，我认为是埃及人发明的。”这是斯科特说的，他很快就把自己定义为聪明人。“希腊人，埃及人，他们都是一回事，”沃尔特说，“总之，你们那教皇不知道的事不会伤害到他。所以闭上臭嘴，开始玩。”
He dealt the cards, and I looked from face to face, exaggerating flaws and reminding myself that these boys did not like me. The hope was that I might kill any surviving atom of attraction. But as has been the case for my entire life, the more someone dislikes me, the more attractive they become. The key was to stall, to argue every hand until the sun came up and Mrs. Winters saved me with whatever cheerful monstrosity she had planned for breakfast.
他发了牌，我看着每一张脸，夸大他们的缺点，提醒自己这些男孩不喜欢我。希望我能以此杀灭任何残留的吸引力。但正如我一生中所经历的那样，某人越不喜欢我，他们就越有吸引力。关键在于拖延，在每一手牌上争论，直到太阳升起，温特斯太太用她计划好的任何欢快的怪物早餐来拯救我。
Usually when forced to compete, it was my tactic to simply give up. To try in any way was to announce your ambition, which only made you more vulnerable. Here though, surrender was not an option. I had to win in a game I knew nothing about. And that seemed hopeless until I realized we were all on an even keel. Not even Scott had the slightest idea what he was doing. And by feigning an air of expertise, I found I could manipulate things in my favor.
通常在被迫竞争时，我的策略就是直接放弃。尝试任何方式都是在宣告你的野心，那只会让你变得更脆弱。但在这里，投降不是选项。我必须在一场我一无所知的游戏中获胜。这看起来毫无希望，直到我意识到我们都在同一起跑线上。即使是斯科特也完全不知道自己在做什么。通过假装专家，我发现我可以操纵局势对我有利。
"A joker and a queen is much better than a four and five of spades," I said, defending my hand against Brad Clancy's. "But you have a joker and a three of diamonds." "Yeah, but the joker makes it a queen." "I thought you said that poker was against your religion," Walt said. "Well that doesn't mean I don't understand it. Greeks invented cards, remember? They're in my blood."
“一张小丑牌加一张皇后牌比一张4加一张5的黑桃好多了，”我说，为我的手牌对抗布拉德·克兰西的牌做辩护。“但你有一张小丑牌和一张3的方块。”“是啊，但小丑牌让它变成了一张皇后。”“我以为你说扑克违背了你的宗教信仰，”沃尔特说。“好吧，这并不意味着我不懂它。希腊人发明了扑克牌，记得吗？它们流淌在我的血液里。”
At the start of the game, the starburst clock had read 3:30. An hour later I was missing one shoe. Scott and Brad had lost their shirts. And both Walt and Dale were down to their underwear. If this was what winning felt like, I wondered why I hadn't tried it earlier. Confidently in the lead, I invented little reasons for the undressed to get up and move about the room. "Hey Walt, did you hear that? Sounded like your mother calling." "I didn't hear anything." "Well why don't you go to the stairway and check? We don't want any surprises." His underwear was all bunchy in the back, saggy like a diaper. But his legs were meaty and satisfying to look at.
比赛开始时，星爆钟显示3点半。一小时后，我少了一只鞋。斯科特和布拉德输掉了衬衫。沃尔特和戴尔只剩下内裤。如果这就是赢的感觉，我纳闷为什么我不早点尝试。自信地处于领先地位，我发明了一些小借口让那些脱了衣服的人站起来四处走动。“嘿沃尔特，你听到了吗？听起来像你妈妈在叫你。”“我没听到什么。”“好吧，你为什么不去楼梯口检查一下？我们可不想有什么意外。”他的内裤在后面挤成一团，松垮垮像尿布。但他的腿很有肉感，看起来很满足。
"Dale, would you make sure those curtains are closed?" He crossed the room, and I ate him alive with my eyes, confident that no one would accuse me of gaping. Things might have been different were I in last place. But as the winner, it was my right to make sure that things were done properly. "There's a little gap down by the baseboard. Bend over and close it, will you?"
“戴尔，你能确保窗帘拉上了吗？”他走过房间，我用眼睛把他生吞活剥了，自信没有人会指责我盯着他看。如果我排在最后，情况可能就不同了。但作为赢家，我有权确保事情做得妥当。“踢脚板那里有个小缝。弯腰把它关上，好吗？”
It took a while, but once I explained that a pair of kings was no match for the two of hearts and a three of spades, Walt surrendered his underpants and tossed them onto the pile beside the TV set. "OK," he said, "now the rest of you can finish the game." "But it is finished," Scott said. "Oh no," Walt said. "I'm not the only one getting naked. You guys have to keep playing." "While you what? Sit and watch?" I said. "What kind of a homo are you?" "Yeah," Dale said. "Why don't we do something else? This game's boring and the rules are impossible."
花了一些时间，但一旦我解释了两个K根本比不过两张红心和一张3的黑桃，沃尔特交出了他的内裤，扔在电视机旁的那堆衣服上。“好了，”他说，“现在你们其他人可以把比赛结束了。”“但已经结束了，”斯科特说。“哦，不，”沃尔特说，“不仅仅是我一个人要脱光。你们这些家伙必须继续玩。”“然后你干嘛？坐着看？”我说，“你是什么样的同性恋？”“是啊，”戴尔说，“我们为什么不干点别的？这游戏真无聊，规则也根本不可能。”
The others muttered their agreement. And when Walt refused to back down, I gathered the deck and tamped it commandingly upon the table top. "The only solution is for us all to keep playing." "Well how the hell do you expect me to do that?" Walt said. "In case you haven't noticed, there's nothing more for me to lose." "Oh," I said, "there's always more. Maybe if the weakest hand is already naked, we should make that person perform some kind of a task. Nothing big, but you know, just a token kind of a thing." "A think like what?" Walt asked. "I don't know. I guess we'll just have to cross that bridge when we come to it."
其他人嘀咕着表示同意。当沃尔特拒绝退让时，我收集起牌组，威严地在桌面上敲了敲。“唯一的解决方案就是我们所有人都继续玩。”“那你到底想让我怎么玩？”沃尔特说，“如果你没注意到的话，我已经没什么可输的了。”“哦，”我说，“总还有更多的。也许如果手牌最差的人已经脱光了，我们应该让那个人执行某种任务。没什么大不了，你知道，就当个象征性的事。”“什么样的任务？”沃尔特问。“我不知道。我想我们得等遇到那座桥的时候再说。”
In retrospect, I probably went a little too far in ordering Scott to sit on my lap. "But I'm naked," he said. "Hey," I said, "I'm the one who's going to be suffering. I was just looking for something easy. Would you rather run outside and touch the mailbox? The sun will be coming up in about 20 seconds. You want the whole neighborhood to see you?" "How long will I have to sit on you?" He asked. "I don't know, a minute or two. Maybe five, or seven."
回想起来，我命令斯科特坐在我大腿上可能有点过分了。“但我没穿衣服，”他说。“嘿，”我说，“受苦的是我。我只是想找点简单的。你宁愿跑出去摸邮箱吗？太阳再过20秒就要出来了。你想让整个街区的人都看见你吗？”“我得坐在你身上多久？”他问。“我不知道，一两分钟。可能五或七分钟。”
I moved on to the easy chair and wearily patted my knee as if this were a great sacrifice. Scott slid into place, and I considered our reflection in the darkened TV screen. Here I was, one naked guy on my lap and three others ready to do my bidding. It was the stuff of dreams until I remembered that they were not doing these things of their own accord. This was not their pleasure but their punishment. And once it was over, they would make it a point to avoid me. Rumors would spread that I had slipped something into their Cokes, that I had tried to French Brad Clancy, that I had stolen $5 from Wade's pocket. Not even Mrs. Winters would wave at me. But all that would come later in a different life.
我移到那把舒适的椅子上，疲惫地拍了拍膝盖，仿佛这是一个巨大的牺牲。斯科特坐了上来，我审视着我们在黑暗电视屏幕上的倒影。我就在这里，大腿上坐着一个裸体男人，另外三个准备听我差遣。这简直是梦想成真，直到我记得他们并非自愿做这些事。这不是他们的快乐，而是他们的惩罚。一旦结束，他们就会特意避开我。谣言会散布开来，说我在他们的可乐里下了药，说我试图强吻布拉德·克兰西，说我从韦德的口袋里偷了5美元。甚至温特斯太太也不会再对我挥手。但那一切都是后话，是在另一个生命中。
For now, I would savor this poor imitation of tenderness, mapping Scott's shoulders, the small of his back, as he shuddered beneath my winning hand.
现在，我要品味这可怜的温柔模仿，描绘着斯科特的肩膀，他的腰部，当他在我的胜券在握之下颤抖时。
David Sedaris is the author of Me Talk Pretty One Day and several other books.
大卫·塞达里斯是《我谈漂亮那一天》及其他几本书的作者。
[MUSIC - "ONE NIGHT OF SIN" BY ELVIS PRESLEY]
[音乐 - 埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的《One Night of Sin》]
Act Two, Playing Clinton in the Bush Leagues. And now the story of another precocious upstart, a winner in this case, someone who people love so much that he went into politics and took on some of the trappings of a minor, very minor, demagogue in the small Texas town of Gun Barrel City. Katy Vine tells this cautionary tale.
第二幕，“在低级别联赛中扮演克林顿”。现在是另一个早熟的新贵的故事，在这个案例中他是个赢家，人们是如此爱他，以至于他投身政治，并在德克萨斯州枪管城这个小镇担任了某种微不足道、非常微不足道的煽动者的角色。凯蒂·范讲述了这个警示故事。
Tye Thomas was one of those kids who appeared destined for success, the one adults look at and say, that kid's going places. The kind of kid who'd buy bulk candy and lottery tickets and hawk them in his classes at a markup of 300%, 400%, sometimes 500%.
泰·托马斯是那种注定会成功的孩子，大人们看着他说，这孩子将来有出息。那种会大量购买糖果和彩票，然后以300%、400%、有时500%的加价在班级里倒卖的孩子。
Now my best idea that I ever had was my dad used to carry me down to the local bar. It was called Captain John's in Gun Barrel City. They have in some Texas bars what they call a jukebox fund. And somebody will go around and collect $1 or $2 from everybody in the bar. And they go stick it in the jukebox. But what I would do is I would go around on a busy day, and collect $1 or $2 or $3 from everybody. And I was so young and cute then, people were just happy to give me the money. But what I'd do is I'd go put about $10 in the jukebox. And whatever was left over I'd stick in my pocket. That's just flat out stealing. However, I made a hell of a lot of money.
我最好的点子是，我爸爸经常带我去当地的一家酒吧。那家酒吧叫枪管城的约翰船长酒吧。德克萨斯的一些酒吧里有所谓的“点唱机基金”。有人会走一圈，从酒吧里的每个人那里收集1或2美元。然后他们把它投进点唱机里。但我会怎么做呢？我会在忙碌的日子里四处走动，从每个人那里收1、2或3美元。那时我很年轻可爱，人们很高兴把钱给我。但我会把大约10美元放进点唱机。剩下的钱我就揣进自己口袋。那根本就是偷窃。不过，我赚了相当多钱。
The elements of most of Tye's stories are contained in this anecdote. He starts with a big idea. The big idea skirts the fine points of the law. Then he feels a little bit guilty about his actions. And he ignores it. When Tye was 15 years old, he founded a little six page newspaper, The Cedar Creek Briefs, which by the time he graduated, he had turned into a 24 page publication, mostly made up of ads. Before he went off to private college, he sold it for more money than his parents' combined income that year.
泰的大多数故事都包含这些元素。他以一个宏大的想法开始。这个想法游走在法律的边缘。然后他会对自己的行为感到一点点内疚。然后他就无视了。泰15岁时，创办了一份六页的小报《雪松溪简报》，到他毕业时，他已经将其变成了一份24页的出版物，主要由广告组成。在他去私立大学之前，他卖掉它的钱比他父母当年的总收入还要多。
After college, he picked up where he left off. He bought the town newspaper, founded another one, and started buying up residential and commercial properties. Once he had his economic empire established, he started building his political empire. He decided to run for mayor. He launched a direct mail campaign. Every day after work, he went door to door asking people to vote for him. He even staffed a phone bank. For a town of 5,000, it was a well-oiled machine. Plus he was running as a reformer.
大学毕业后，他重操旧业。他买了镇上的报纸，创办了另一份，并开始大量购买住宅和商业地产。一旦建立了他的经济帝国，他就开始建立他的政治帝国。他决定竞选市长。他发起了直接邮寄竞选活动。每天下班后，他挨家挨户请求人们投票给他。他甚至还配置了一个电话银行。对于一个5000人的小镇来说，这是一台运转良好的机器。况且他是以改革者的身份竞选的。
When Tye Thomas came on the scene in Gun Barrel City as a political figure, Gun Barrel City was somewhat of a laughing stock.
当泰·托马斯作为政治人物出现在枪管城时，枪管城在某种程度上是个笑话。
Mike Hannigan is the editor of the Cedar Creek Pilot , which had been the main competing newspaper to Tye's two newspapers.
迈克·汉尼根是《雪松溪领航员》的编辑，该报一直是泰两份报纸的主要竞争对手。
We had a city manager that one time came out and said someone had put a bomb under his car. And it ended up being a jug of gasoline. And this is a town that was coming off of watching our mayor kick in a door in City Hall on TV. And Tye Thomas looked like the kind of guy that would make that kind of stuff go away. He knew how to sell things. He knew how to sell himself. People believed that he would be able to sell Gun Barrel City. I mean he was a young guy, new ideas, good personality, had a great smile. Everybody liked him. How could this kid get us into trouble?
我们有位城市经理曾有一次跳出来说有人在他车下放了炸弹。最后发现那只是一个汽油罐。这就是一个刚看着我们的市长在电视上踢开市政厅大门的镇子。而泰·托马斯看起来像是那种能让这些破事消失的人。他知道如何推销东西。他知道如何推销自己。人们相信他有能力推销枪管城。我的意思是，他是个年轻人，有新点子，性格好，笑容灿烂。每个人都喜欢他。这孩子怎么会让我们惹上麻烦？
On election day, Tye went down to City Hall, where the secretary had posted the results. He had won 67% of the vote, a landslide. He was 21 years old.
选举日那天，泰去了市政厅，秘书已经公布了结果。他赢得了67%的选票，大获全胜。他21岁。
You know after three months of working for something, I felt like doing cartwheels in the parking lot. I felt like taking my clothes off and running down the highway naked. But I contained myself. I remember I wrote a journal entry the next morning, that next Sunday morning, May 7, And it felt so weird waking up on the couch-- because I sleep on the couch every night-- it felt so weird waking up on the couch knowing that I was now the mayor of my city.
你知道，为一件事工作了三个月后，我觉得自己想在停车场翻跟头。我觉得自己想脱掉衣服在高速公路上裸奔。但我克制住了自己。我记得那天第二天早上，也就是5月7日那个星期天早上，我写了日记。在那沙发上醒来感觉很奇怪——因为我每晚都睡在沙发上——在那沙发上醒来知道自己现在是这个城市的市长，感觉真奇怪。
A lot of people can win an election. But to win an election in a landslide usually takes a certain kind of politician, one who motivates the community and one who also feeds off the affirmation of his people. Tye Thomas is one of those politicians.
很多人都能赢得选举。但要以压倒性优势赢得选举，通常需要某种特定的政客，一个能够激励社区，同时也从人们的肯定中汲取力量的人。泰·托马斯就是那种政客。
The first three or four months after I was elected were I would have to say probably the greatest four months of my life, looking back. I was invited often to speak to groups to share my vision for the city. I received lots of positive press, lots of great publicity. The city was receiving wonderful publicity as a result of my winning the election. I was working on the promise that I would return the peace and the serenity to City Hall, which I didn't do. I actually probably made it worse.
回头来看，我当选后的头三四个月可能是我一生中最美好的四个月。我经常被邀请去向团体发表演讲，分享我对城市的愿景。我收到了很多积极的媒体报道，很多很棒的宣传。因为我的当选，这个城市获得了美妙的宣传。我致力于实现我将把和平与宁静带回市政厅的承诺，但我没有做到。我实际上可能把事情弄得更糟了。
One of the things that makes Tye such a remarkable character is that he's so candid. His candor was refreshing, maybe even necessary, for success in a town whose motto was "we shoot you straight." But in politics, like in all sorts of careers, there are just some times you are better off keeping your mouth shut. Again, editor Mike Hannigan.
让泰成为如此杰出人物的原因之一是他非常坦率。他的坦率令人耳目一新，甚至可能是在一个座右铭是“我们直言不讳”的镇子上成功所必需的。但在政治中，就像在各种职业中一样，有些时候你最好还是闭上嘴。再次引用编辑迈克·汉尼根的话。
I remember the time he went on a Dallas radio station for a win a date with the mayor contest, where they actually had women calling in and talking to Tye and Tye talking to them. And one of them got to have a date with Tye Thomas.
我记得他曾去达拉斯的一家广播电台参加“赢取与市长约会”的比赛，那里真的有女性打来电话和泰交谈，泰也和她们谈话。其中一位真的和泰·托马斯约会了。
So somebody did win a date?
所以真的有人赢得了约会？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Were people in the community embarrassed, though, that he did that?
但社区里的人会因为他那样做而感到尴尬吗？
People in the community were horrified. One of the best examples was he goes to a bar and admittedly-- in a newspaper article admits that he drank a little too much and didn't think he should be driving home. So the first thing he thought of was to call the police to give him a hand, call for a police escort home. And all this is not quite what the average person would think that the police was supposed to be doing. But Tye never gave it a second thought. I mean hey, he was in trouble. The police were there to serve. I'm Tye Thomas. Let me give them a call.
社区里的人感到震惊。最好的例子之一就是他去酒吧，而且承认——在报纸文章中承认他喝多了，觉得不应该开车回家。所以他想到的第一件事就是打警察局寻求帮助，叫警车护送回家。而这一切并不完全是普通人认为警察应该做的事。但泰从来没想过第二次。我的意思是，嘿，他遇到了麻烦。警察就是为民服务的。我是泰·托马斯。让我给他们打个电话。
There is more than one story like this about Tye stretching the boundaries of what was acceptable. They eventually led to a DA investigation. And on April 27, 2001, Tye was indicted by a grand jury on perjury charges, a Class A misdemeanor. He was accused of lying about his residency in the town on his application for mayor. Remember, Tye was the town hero. He had won in a landslide, which is maybe why he assumed the public would give him the benefit of the doubt. And so Tye Thomas did what a lot of popular politicians accused of wrongdoing have done before him. He denied the charges. He said the attack was politically motivated. Tye says his problems started right after he declared publicly that he wanted to run for state rep against an incumbent named Clyde Alexander.
关于泰挑战可接受底线的故事不止这一个。它们最终导致了地区检察官的调查。2001年4月27日，泰被大陪审团以伪证罪起诉，这是一项A级轻罪。他被指控在申请市长职位时谎报在镇上的居住情况。记住，泰是镇上的英雄。他以压倒性优势获胜，也许这就是为什么他认为公众会给他宽容。于是泰·托马斯做了很多被指控有不当行为的受欢迎政客以前做过的事。他否认了指控。他说这次攻击是政治动机。泰说他的麻烦始于他公开宣布想竞选州代表，挑战现任者克莱德·亚历山大之后。
That's when all of my troubles began. That's when his ally, Democrat District Attorney Donna Bennett opened up all of her investigations into me and things I had done in the past. She used investigations as a political war tool to discredit my character and my job that I was doing as mayor.
那就是我所有麻烦开始的时候。那就是他的盟友，民主党地区检察官唐娜·贝内特对我以及我过去所做的事展开所有调查的时候。她利用调查作为政治战工具来抹黑我的人格，以及我作为市长所做的工作。
There is, of course, one problem with this conspiracy theory. And that is that the incumbent, Clyde Alexander, didn't run. In any case, it shouldn't have mattered. Mike Hannigan.
当然，这个阴谋论有一个问题。那就是现任者克莱德·亚历山大根本没参选。无论如何，这都不重要。迈克·汉尼根。
Now I think Tye probably could have survived all of that. But that's when he went to the alcohol, and the drugs, and the Xanax.
现在我认为泰本来可能从这一切中幸存下来的。但那就是他开始酗酒、吸毒和服用赞安诺的时候。
It was a Monday morning. The grand jury was the upcoming Thursday. Even though I knew beyond a shadow of a doubt that I was not guilty of the crimes that she was trying to present against me, there was this little voice in my head that's saying, Golly, four to 20 years in prison? I'd rather die. I was scared. I've got to admit to you, Monday morning I woke up at about 7 o'clock and I was scared to death. And I took two, or three, or four Xanax. I can't remember how many. Xanax is an anti-anxiety medication that my doctor prescribes to me.
那是一个星期一的早上。大陪审团的会议在那个星期四。尽管我毫无疑问地知道我并没有犯下她试图向我指控的那些罪行，但我脑子里有一个小声音说，天哪，四到20年的牢狱之灾？我宁愿死。我很害怕。我必须向你承认，星期一早上我大约7点醒来，我被吓死了。我吃了两片、三片或四片赞安诺。我不记得吃了多少了。赞安诺是我医生给我开的一种抗焦虑药物。
And then that evening I went out and I started drinking vodka tonics. And by the end of the evening, I was drinking straight vodka. And I was completely and totally intoxicated. Well I don't know when, but sometime later I vomited, because I had had so much to drink. And I was still asleep on the couch. My ex-fiancee [? Kathy ?] decides to come over. She finds me passed out on the couch in a pool of vomit. She picks up the phone and calls 911, and tells the dispatcher that she was in the mayor's condo and that he had overdosed on Xanax.
那天晚上我出去开始喝伏特加汤力。到了晚上结束时，我在喝纯伏特加。我完全、彻底地醉了。嗯，我不知道是什么时候，但后来我呕吐了，因为我喝得太多了。我仍然在沙发上睡着。我的前未婚妻凯西决定过来。她发现我醉倒在沙发上，躺在呕吐物中。她拿起电话打了911，告诉接线员她在市长的公寓里，他服用赞安诺过量了。
I didn't wake up until there were about six police officers in my house and about eight paramedics. She'd made a 911 call, which is public record. And I knew that the newspaper would pick up on that. And boy it would be the hot story that week. So in some nutso, idiot, ridiculous, drunken state of mind, I decided I wanted to go to jail.
直到屋里有大约六名警察和八名医护人员，我才醒来。她打了911报警电话，这是公共记录。我知道报纸会报道这件事。天哪，那会是那一周的热门新闻。所以在某种疯狂、愚蠢、荒唐、醉酒的状态下，我决定我想坐牢。
Gun Barrel Police Department.
枪管城警察局。
Who's speaking, Red?
谁在说话，雷德？
This is Red.
我是雷德。
Red, this is Mayor Thomas.
雷德，我是市长托马斯。
Get ?] off the phone.
滚蛋。
I need an officer to come and immediately arrest me.
我需要一名警官立刻过来逮捕我。
What's the emergency?
什么紧急情况？
I am guilty of public intoxication. And I need to be taken to jail.
我犯了公共场合醉酒罪。我需要被带进监狱。
Well, you can't be publicly intoxicated in your own home, sir.
嗯，先生，你在自己家里不能算在公共场合醉酒。
Well, I'll be in the parking lot.
好吧，我会去停车场的。
Mr. Mayor, as soon as I got one available, I'll send him right away.
市长先生，我一有人手就会立刻派人过去。
And I think I called five or six times. I didn't know what I said until my competitor newspaper got a copy of all the 911 tapes, and so did the TV stations in Dallas, and played them. It was pretty embarrassing to hear yourself drunk on the 10 o'clock news.
我想我打了五六次。我不知道自己说了什么，直到我的竞争对手报纸拿到了所有911录音的副本，达拉斯的电视台也拿到了，并播放了它们。在10点新闻里听到自己醉酒的样子真是太尴尬了。
These days, having attended his share of AA meetings, Tye Thomas will be the first to admit that he had problems with substance abuse. But you get the sense that he first grasped the seriousness of his trouble just as it was being broadcast to everyone in the Dallas-Forth Worth area. The incident was the nail in the coffin. 21 days later, he resigned as mayor.
这些天，参加过几次戒酒互助会会议后，泰·托马斯会第一个承认他有药物滥用问题。但你会觉得他是在麻烦事被向整个达拉斯-沃斯堡地区广播时，才第一次抓住了严重性。这件事是棺材上的最后一颗钉子。21天后，他辞去了市长职务。
Afterwards, he had bouts of depression. He sat in his condo with the blinds closed for days at a time, not bathing, wearing only his bathrobe. He became paranoid, and went so far as to re-shred paper shreddings in his apartment. He thought he was being watched. Eventually he left town.
之后，他陷入了抑郁。他一连几天拉着百叶窗坐在公寓里，不洗澡，只穿着浴袍。他变得多疑，甚至去重新粉碎公寓里的纸屑。他以为自己被监视了。最终他离开了小镇。
One of the most striking things about the whole episode is the extremes of Tye's confidence and his fragility. It seems strange. How can somebody who had such absolute faith in his ability to lead be dragged into a drug and alcohol spiral by charges he could have beaten? But at least in Tye's case, the confidence and fragility seem linked. They both come from a failure to anticipate the thought that occurs to all the rest of us as second nature. What if I fail? What if I can't lead? What if they don't like me? It's a very innocent thought. Tye had an innocence about other people's faith in him and an innocence about his faith in himself.
整个事件中最引人注目的是泰的自信与脆弱之间的极端对比。这看起来很奇怪。一个对领导能力有绝对信心的人怎么会被他本来可以打赢的指控拖进毒品和酒精的漩涡呢？但至少在泰的案例中，自信和脆弱似乎是联系在一起的。它们都源于未能预见那个对我们其他人来说是第二天性会想到的念头。如果我失败了怎么办？如果我不能领导怎么办？如果他们不喜欢我怎么办？那是一个非常天真的想法。泰对于别人对他的信仰有一种天真，对他自己对自己的信仰也有种天真。
You see when I ran for mayor, and after I was first elected, I really felt that emotionally and mentally I was invincible. I didn't believe that anything or anybody could change my self-esteem or the way that I felt about myself. And I was dead wrong.
你看，当我竞选市长时，以及我第一次当选后，我真的觉得在情感上和精神上我是不可战胜的。我不相信任何事或任何人能改变我的自尊或我对自己的感觉。但我大错特错了。
If you could maybe wipe the town memory absolutely clean, would you go back and try again?
如果你能把这个镇的记忆彻底抹掉，你会回去再试一次吗？
No.
不会。
If they had no memory of who Tye Thomas was and you were going in for the first time?
如果他们完全不记得泰·托马斯是谁，而你是第一次进去？
No, I wouldn't go back.
不会，我不会回去。
How come?
为什么？
I've become very sensitive to how situations that I place myself in are going to affect me emotionally. And that's not something I would ever put myself through again. Even if it had a completely different outcome, even if I knew beyond a shadow of a doubt that it was going to be positive, I wouldn't go back and do it.
我对自身所处的环境如何影响我的情绪变得非常敏感。那不是我会再让自己经历一次的事情。即使结果完全不同，即使我毫无疑问地知道它会是积极的，我也不会回去做这件事。
Despite all that, as Mike Hannigan points out, his term wasn't exactly a failure.
尽管如此，正如迈克·汉尼根指出的那样，他的任期并不完全是个失败。
He made himself into exactly what he wanted to make himself into. He became a public figure, almost an icon.
他把自己塑造成了他想塑造的样子。他成为了一个公众人物，几乎是一个偶像。
Light a fire within you. Some will come and join you. And others will come just to watch you burn. And back then, I had a strong fire going with me. And people couldn't get enough of it.
点燃你心中的火焰。有些人会加入你。有些人则会仅仅为了看着你燃烧而来。那时，我心中燃着熊熊烈火。人们对此如痴如醉。
Tye Thomas has an unholy hold on the Gun Barrel City imagination. He has been gone for years now, and I still get phone calls with people telling me, hey, he just did this. Hey, he just did that.
泰·托马斯在枪管城的想象中占有一种不圣的统治力。他已经离开多年了，但我仍然会接到电话，有人告诉我，嘿，他刚才做了这个。嘿，他刚才做了那个。
Let me tell you, it's a wonderful feeling to go to the newsstand and buy a newspaper and not have to worry about your picture or name being on the front page. At first I loved it. And now that's something that I grew to despise.
让我告诉你，去报刊亭买份报纸，不用担心自己的照片或名字出现在头版上，那是一种美妙的感觉。起初我很喜欢它，而现在那是我开始鄙视的事情。
Some politicians take a lifetime to get to the point Tye got to in a year. The stunning rise to the top, the scandal, and the fall from grace. Tye says he hasn't entirely ruled out a future run for office. But he figures he'll have to wait at least 15 years before he can claim it's all behind him, that he's someone else. So he waits. He's not even 25.
有些政客花了一辈子才达到泰在一年内达到的地步。令人惊叹的崛起，丑闻，以及失宠后的跌落。泰说他并没有完全排除未来竞选公职的可能。但他觉得他至少得等15年，才能声称这一切都已经过去了，他已经变成了另一个人。所以他等待着。他甚至还不到25岁。
Katy Vine is a writer for the magazine Texas Monthly . Coming up, US officials, many of them young and charming, come into Iraq carrying their message of hope, and democracy, and freedom. And why even the Iraqis who want to hear that message don't seem to. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
凯蒂·范是《德克萨斯月刊》杂志的撰稿人。接下来，美国官员，许多人年轻而迷人，带着关于希望、民主和自由的信息来到伊拉克。为什么连那些想听到这些信息的伊拉克人似乎都听不进去。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, I'm in Charge Here, stories of people who get filled with American entrepreneurial spirit to take over, create something new, full of self confidence, and what sometimes happens to them.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的报道。今天的节目，“这里我做主”，讲述的是那些充满美国创业精神，接手并创造新事物，充满自信的人，以及有时发生在他们身上的事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, You Talkin' to Me? Nearly every day, there's some story from Iraq about how badly the US occupation there is going. Soldiers getting shot, basic services still not working. And one of the big problems there is the information gap between the Iraqis and the Americans who are running the country. One small, telling sign of that gap, even the name of the agency running the country hasn't gotten out to most Iraqis. That agency's name? It's called the Coalition Provisional Authority, or CPA. When Iraqis know any name, it's usually the name the agency used to be called, ORHA, the Office of Reconstruction and Humanitarian Assistance. Well, reporter Adam Davidson says the information gap is one of the most ominous things about living in Baghdad these days.
我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，“你在跟我说话吗？”几乎每天，都有关于伊拉克美军占领进展得多么糟糕的新闻。士兵中枪，基本服务依然无法运作。而那里的一大问题是伊拉克人和管理这个国家的美国人之间的信息鸿沟。这个鸿沟的一个小小的、显著的迹象是，连管理这个国家的机构名称都没有传达到大多数伊拉克人那里。那个机构的名字？它叫“联盟临时管理局”，简称CPA。当伊拉克人知道名字时，通常是该机构以前的名字，ORHA，“重建和人道主义援助办公室”。嗯，记者亚当·戴维森说，信息鸿沟是这些天在巴格达生活最令人担忧的事情之一。
There's an information void. And as a result, rumors are everywhere. Amjad, my translator, tells me the new ones every morning. And then I hear them repeated by different people all day. People say the Americans are burning Iraqi currency in big trash barrels at gas stations, because they want Iraqis to be poor. They say Israelis are buying up the most valuable real estate in Iraq so they can occupy Iraq just like Palestine.
存在一个信息真空。结果，谣言无处不在。我的翻译阿姆贾德每天早上都告诉我新的谣言。然后我整天听到不同的人重复这些谣言。人们说美国人在加油站的垃圾桶里烧掉伊拉克货币，因为他们想让伊拉克人变穷。他们说以色列人正在购买伊拉克最有价值的房地产，这样他们就能像巴勒斯坦一样占领伊拉克。
Then there's the rumor you hear most often, that Saddam Hussein is living in the US somewhere in a big mansion. I hear this all the time, that Saddam worked with the Americans, arranged for the American invasion so that the US could take over the country and steal its oil. In the last few weeks this rumor has changed a bit. People now say Saddam is living in the White House.
然后是那种你听到最频繁的谣言，即萨达姆·侯赛因住在美国某处的豪宅里。我一直听到这个，说萨达姆与美国人合作，安排了美国入侵，以便美国可以接管国家并窃取石油。在过去几周，这个谣言稍微改变了一点。人们现在说萨达姆住在白宫里。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Whether the rumor is right or correct or not, what we do is convey the rumor by itself without giving our own point of view or our own opinion about this rumor.
不管谣言是对是错，我们所做的只是传达谣言本身，而不给出我们自己的观点或对这个谣言的评价。
Mustafa publishes Al-Saah, The Clock, one of the newspapers that have sprung up in Baghdad since the fall of Saddam Hussein. So many papers have appeared that nobody knows exactly how many there are. The last count I heard was 105. Mustafa tells me the paper has 30 reporters. Every day they try to find some American somewhere who will answer their questions.
穆斯塔法出版了《时钟》，这是萨达姆·侯赛因倒台后在巴格达涌现的报纸之一。出现了这么多报纸，没人确切知道有多少。我听到的最新统计是105份。穆斯塔法告诉我报社有30名记者。他们每天都在尝试在某处找到一个愿意回答他们问题的美国人。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
We need to interview members of ORHA personally to ask them their questions, to know their feelings, to know what kind of measures they are taking.
我们需要亲自采访ORHA的成员来询问他们问题，了解他们的感受，了解他们正在采取什么样的措施。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
We always try to get information from ORHA. We are always sending our reporters there to the office. But they found difficulties in getting this information.
我们总是试图从ORHA获取信息。我们总是派记者去他们的办公室。但他们发现获取这些信息很困难。
So they're left printing rumors. One issue of Al-Saah reported that American soldiers were giving pornography to schoolgirls, another rumor I heard a lot. Another explained how the Americans had promised to give $50 to every Iraqi. The photo on the front page was of an American soldier attacking an older man. In red writing along the sides there was a prayer, "Merciful God, deliver us from this damnation." All this was an Arabic, along with editorials denouncing the US occupation.
所以他们只能印刷谣言。《时钟》的一期报道说美国士兵在给女学生发放色情制品，这是我听到的另一个谣言。另一篇解释了美国人是如何承诺给每个伊拉克人50美元的。头版的照片是一名美国士兵在攻击一位老人。侧面用红色文字写着祈祷，“仁慈的上帝，从这诅咒中解救我们吧。”所有这些都是阿拉伯语，还有谴责美国占领的社论。
But like a lot of Iraqi newspapers, one of Al-Saah's eight pages is in English. The English page seems to come from some other newspaper. It's completely pro-American. The photo on that page was of a friendly female soldier giving a bottle of water to a grateful young Iraqi girl. There's an article about how the Americans had helped to open a school. As one reporter told me, the English page is for the Americans to read, so they won't get mad at Al-Saah. The Arabic pages are for the Iraqis.
但像许多伊拉克报纸一样，《时钟》八页中的一页是英语。英文版看起来像是来自其他报纸。它完全是亲美的。那一页的照片是一名友好的女兵给一个感激的年轻伊拉克女孩送去一瓶水。有一篇关于美国人如何帮助开设学校的文章。正如一位记者告诉我的，英语版是给美国人看的，这样他们就不会对《时钟》生气。阿拉伯语版是给伊拉克人看的。
In general, Iraqis know the Americans are in charge. But they have no idea what the Americans here are up to. Most people have heard of Paul Bremer, the guy who's in charge of Iraq right now. But they don't know anything about him. These men were standing near the [? Jamuhuri ?] Bridge, about a block from the American headquarters in Iraq.
总的来说，伊拉克人知道美国人在掌管一切。但他们不知道这里的美国人在干什么。大多数人都听说过保罗·布雷默，现在掌管伊拉克的人。但他们对他一无所知。这些人在距离伊拉克美军总部约一个街区的贾姆胡里大桥附近站着。
What have you heard from the Americans about what their plans are?
你们从美国人那里听到了关于他们有什么计划的消息吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I heard nothing. I heard nothing from them.
我什么都没听到。我没从他们那里听到任何消息。
What do you know about Bremer? What do you know about Bremer?
关于布雷默你们知道些什么？关于布雷默你们知道些什么？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I don't anything. If he--
我不知道任何事。如果他——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Only promises. Only promises. That's all I know about Bremer.
只有承诺。只有承诺。关于布雷默我只知道这些。
If he were walking down the street, would you recognize him?
如果他走在街上，你们认得出他吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
No. No. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
不。不。[阿拉伯语发言]
If he was walking along we don't know him. Maybe you are Bremer.
如果他走过来我们不知道他。也许你就是布雷默。
Talking to people in Baghdad, I've thought a lot about what it would be like to be back home in America if the situation were reversed. If there were this group of Iraqis who don't speak English running my country, knowing they're making plans that will affect every part of my life and not knowing anything about what those plans are. Not even knowing anything about who those people are. One thing you hear all the time is if the Americans wanted to fix all this with all their money and power, they could. So the only explanation is they don't care. Or worse, they want Iraqis to suffer.
在巴格达与人交谈时，我经常想到如果情况反过来，回到美国会是什么样子。如果有一群不会说英语的伊拉克人运行我的国家，知道他们在制定会影响我生活方方面面的计划，却对这些计划一无所知。甚至对这些人是谁一无所知。有一点你经常听到，那就是如果美国人想用他们所有的钱和权力解决这一切，他们是可以做到的。所以唯一的解释是他们不在乎。或者更糟，他们想让伊拉克人受苦。
The headquarters of the US administration in Iraq is right in the center of Baghdad, Saddam's Republican Palace. It's like a fortress. All you can see from the street is barbed concertina wire and a whole lot of US infantry. In the distance is this large arch and, through it, a tree-lined road. It's like a small city in there. This was Saddam's main governmental complex, a huge area, big enough that the US has set up bus routes inside with dozens of buildings and thousands of Americans living and working there.
美军在伊拉克的管理总部就在巴格达市中心，萨达姆的共和国宫。它就像一座堡垒。从街上你只能看到铁丝网和大量的美国步兵。远处是这个巨大的拱门，通过它，是一条林荫道。那里面就像一个小城市。这是萨达姆的主要政府大楼，一个巨大的区域，大到美国人在里面建立了公交线路，有几十栋大楼，成千上万的美国人在那里生活和工作。
And this gate is like the border between the country of Iraq and the American country within a country. It's where US soldiers shot and killed protesters this week who were throwing stones. Every day there's a crowd of Iraqis at the entrance off to one side of all that barbed wire. They're trying to get in there, hoping to talk to someone in charge about whatever problem they're having.
而这个大门就像伊拉克国家和美国内部国家之间的边界。这是本周美军士兵射杀投掷石块的抗议者的地方。每天都有大群伊拉克人在所有铁丝网的一侧入口处。他们试图进去，希望能和负责的人谈谈他们遇到的任何问题。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Two women are there dressed in their best clothes, like they were going to a job interview. They're principals, they say, and they want to talk to whichever American is in charge of the Ministry of Education. In all the postwar confusion, some guy no one knew just showed up one day, and said he's now in charge of their school district. He's awful, they say, bossing everyone around and stealing money. They want a different guy to be placed in charge. Someone prepared a letter for them, which neither can read because they don't know English.
两名女性穿着她们最好的衣服在那里，就像要去参加工作面试一样。她们说她们是校长，想和负责教育部的美国人谈谈。在战后所有的混乱中，一个没人认识的家伙某天突然出现，说他现在负责他们的学区。她们说他很糟糕，对每个人颐指气使，还偷钱。她们想换个负责的人。有人为她们准备了一封信，但两人都读不懂，因为她们不懂英语。
Hey, tell these people to back up.
嘿，告诉这些人后退。
A soldier comes up and tells them to get back from the gate. They don't know what he's saying, and he doesn't know what they're saying. So they keep standing there and eventually the soldier walks away. It turns out this is the wrong gate if you want to talk to an American.
一名士兵走过来叫她们离大门远点。她们不知道他在说什么，他也不知道她们在说什么。所以她们继续站在那里，最终士兵走开了。原来如果你想和美国人谈话，这里走错了门。
There is a right gate. It's off to the side behind a bunch of trees where army specialist Laura Moore, a 21 year old in the Civil Affairs Corps, is standing behind some barbed concertina wire. She has blue eyes and blond hair that comes down out of her bulletproof helmet. You can just picture her walking around a mall back home with her friends. And here she is, the face of the US occupation of Iraq. In the whole country, only Laura Moore and a small number of co-workers have the job of meeting with average Iraqis, finding out what's bothering them and trying to offer solutions.
有个正确的门。它在树林后面的一侧，美国民政部门21岁的士兵劳拉·摩尔正站在铁丝网后面。她有着蓝眼睛和金色头发，从防弹头盔下露出来。你可以想象她在家乡和朋友们在商场散步的样子。而在这里，她是美军占领伊拉克的面孔。在整个国家，只有劳拉·摩尔和少数同事有任务与普通伊拉克人会面，找出困扰他们的问题并试图提供解决方案。
Even though she could move into the shade of the trees, she stands with a translator out in the hot sun. A few yards away, there is a long line of Iraqis who are also standing in the sun. Most of them are older men, and they look sick like they're wilting in the 115 degree heat. When they are waved over, they walk up to the barbed wire and tell their problems to Moore's not very good translator, who does his best in a kind of broken English to tell Moore what they're saying. Then he translates her response. It's all sorts of things. People want money.
尽管她可以移到树荫下，但她和翻译站在炎炎烈日下。几码远的地方，是一长排也站在太阳底下的伊拉克人。他们大多数是上了年纪的男人，看起来病恹恹的，好像在115华氏度的高温下枯萎了一样。当被招手示意过来时，他们走到铁丝网旁，向摩尔那个不怎么样的翻译诉说他们的问题，翻译尽其所能地用蹩脚的英语告诉摩尔他们在说什么。然后他翻译她的回应。各种各样的问题。人们想要钱。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
He has a car which was looted one month ago.
他的车在一个月前被抢走了。
OK, he's going to have to take his civil complaint to the police academy.
好吧，他必须把他的民事诉讼带到警察学院去。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Unfortunately, there's really nothing that we can do for you right here. If the Police Academy is working your situation, hopefully they'll find your car soon, OK? Now for temporary aid, I'm going to advise you to go to the Red Crescent in Mansour, because hopefully they'll be able to help you out financially, something like that. Maybe help you get your feet back on the ground and get a new car, OK?
不幸的是，我们在这里真的无能为力。如果警察学院正在处理你的情况，希望他们很快能找到你的车，好吗？现在为了临时援助，我建议你去曼苏尔的红新月会，因为希望他们能在经济上帮助你，之类的。也许能帮助你重新站稳脚跟，买辆新车，好吗？
Moore says this is what she does pretty much every time. The Iraqis talk to her, and then she tells them she can't help them and tells them to go away. She says nobody gets past the gate. Nobody gets inside the palace to talk to whoever will decide their case. It's for safety reasons.
摩尔说她几乎每次都这么做。伊拉克人跟她说话，然后她告诉他们她帮不了他们，并让他们离开。她说没人能过得了大门。没人能进去宫殿和决定他们案件的人谈话。这是出于安全原因。
Is it hard sending people away like that?
那样赶走人很难受吗？
You get worse cases than that. And I see about anywhere between 85 and 100 people a day. So--
你看到的案件比那更糟糕。而且我每天大约看85到100人。所以——
You're getting used to it.
你正在习惯它。
You get used to it.
你会习惯的。
A few times a day, someone has a complaint that the Army can actually do something about, like their car or their house was destroyed by the US military. With those people, Moore takes their information, and says someone will look it over, make a decision and get back to them in two months. She always says two months. Of course, there are no working phones in most parts of Baghdad. And there is no postal service. So it's not clear how she'll get back to anybody.
每天有几次，有人有美军实际上可以做点什么的投诉，比如他们的车或房子被美军摧毁了。对于那些人，摩尔记录他们的信息，并说会有人查看，做决定并在两个月内回复他们。她总是说两个月。当然，巴格达大部分地区没有可用的电话。而且没有邮政服务。所以不清楚她将如何回复任何人。
Are you learning any Arabic?
你在学阿拉伯语吗？
A little. Just some basic greetings, and "thank you," and "two months."
学了一点。只是一些基本的问候，还有“谢谢”，和“两个月”。
Say all that stuff. Say it.
说说看。说吧。
Two months? [SPEAKING ARABIC], come back in two months.
两个月？[阿拉伯语发言]，两个月后再来。
After watching her for 45 minutes, my translator Amjad and I sit under a tree to get out of the sun.
观察了她45分钟后，我的翻译阿姆贾德和我坐在树下躲避太阳。
Amjad, you seem very angry right now.
阿姆贾德，你现在看起来很生气。
When I saw these people, it immediately comes to my mind what was the Iraqi suffering during Saddam Hussein. You can find the same queues asking for jobs, asking their government to give them back their properties. The same things, no difference.
当我看到这些人时，我脑子里立刻出现了伊拉克人在萨达姆·侯赛因统治下遭受的苦难。你可以发现同样的排队求职，求政府归还他们的财产。同样的事情，没区别。
And are the Americans more helpful?
而美国人有帮助吗？
No, they're following the same procedures. Come tomorrow, come after one month, come after two months and we'll see. We'll find out what we can do for you. And I'm sure, I'm positively sure, that they can't do anything for them.
不，他们遵循同样的程序。明天来，一个月后再来，两个月后再来，我们会看看。我们会弄清楚我们能为你做什么。而且我肯定，我绝对肯定，他们对他们什么都做不了。
Privately, some US officials say things didn't need to get this bad, that the gap between Iraqis and Americans didn't need to be so vast, that we should have done in Iraq what we've done after other wars. Once victory was declared, Americans needed to be out in the streets in big numbers listening to Iraqis, holding town meetings, letting Iraqis see them and get to know them, building trust. But because of security concerns-- soldiers are still shot at every day in Iraq. Over 40 have died since the war officially ended-- Americans aren't doing that.
私下里，一些美国官员说事情本来不至于变得这么糟糕，伊拉克人和美国人之间的差距本来不至于如此巨大，我们本来应该在伊拉克做我们在其他战争后做过的事。一旦胜利宣布，美国人需要成群结队地走上街头听取伊拉克人的声音，召开市政会议，让伊拉克人看到他们并了解他们，建立信任。但因为安全问题——士兵们在伊拉克每天仍在遭到枪击。自战争正式结束以来已有40多人死亡——美国人没有那样做。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Curious to see what happens when Americans try to bridge the information gap and meet directly with Iraqis, I sat in as a group of influential Iraqis met with some American representatives. It wasn't very promising. This was a group of tribal sheiks who are more powerful in Iraq then you'd probably think. Though Iraq is a modern country with a lot of educated people and a big middle class, most Iraqis belong to a tribe. And every tribe has a sheik. A sheik can call on his people to do all sorts of things, to boycott something or to march. It's the sheik who decides when a tribe will pick up arms and go to battle. Even Saddam Hussein was scared enough of these guys to meet with them and listen to them.
出于好奇想看看当美国人试图弥合信息差距并直接与伊拉克人会面时会发生什么，我旁听了一次有影响力的伊拉克人与一些美国代表的会面。这并不怎么有希望。这是一群部落酋长，他们在伊拉克的影响力比你可能想到的要大。虽然伊拉克是一个现代化国家，有很多受过教育的人和庞大的中产阶级，但大多数伊拉克人属于某个部落。每个部落都有一个酋长。酋长可以号召他的人民做各种各样的事情，抵制某事或游行。是酋长决定部落何时拿起武器去战斗。即使是萨达姆·侯赛因也对这些人感到恐惧，以至于要会见他们并听取他们的意见。
This is the third meeting like this for the sheiks. A few hundred of them representing most of Iraq's tribes sit in a big theater. At a table on the stage is Hume Horan, counsel to the head of the US coalition, Paul Bremer. Horan speaks Arabic quite well. And he's sitting next to five sheiks.
这是酋长们第三次进行这样的会面。几百名代表伊拉克大部分部落的酋长坐在一个大剧院里。舞台上的桌边是休姆·霍兰，美国联盟首脑保罗·布雷默的顾问。霍兰的阿拉伯语说得很好。他旁边坐着五位酋长。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
The sheiks on stage are among the few who have strongly allied themselves with the Americans. They each give a speech about how much good the Americans have done, how all the sheiks have to stay unified and work with the Americans. No sheik should start any trouble. They're interrupted all the time by sheiks in the audience screaming out questions and complaints. The sheiks on stage tell them not to interrupt, that all their questions will be answered by the speeches that are being given. Everyone will see that all their problems are already being taken care of.
台上的酋长是少数强烈与美国人结盟的人。他们每个人都发表演讲，称赞美国人做了多少好事，所有酋长必须保持团结并与美国人合作。没有任何酋长应该惹事生非。他们一直被台下大声尖叫提出问题和抱怨的酋长打断。台上的酋长告诉他们不要打断，所有问题都会在即将发表的演讲中得到回答。每个人都会看到他们所有的问题都已经被解决了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
In his speech, Horan keeps it general and upbeat. He tells the crowd that he hopes many of them will become his close friends. He says the sheiks' concerns, electricity, security, water, are not a big problem. The Americans have done so much good, he says. Iraq is much safer now. There's plenty of electricity. And anyway, none of it is America's fault. All the problems Iraqis face these days are because of all the bad things Saddam did when he was in power. But the Americans are on the job, and everything's fine now, and we'll get better soon.
在演讲中，霍兰保持了概括性和乐观。他告诉人群，希望他们中的许多人成为他的密友。他说酋长们关心的电、安全、水，都不是什么大问题。他说美国人做了那么多好事。伊拉克现在安全多了。电力充足。无论如何，这些都不是美国的错。伊拉克人这些天面临的所有问题都是因为萨达姆掌权时做的所有坏事。但美国人正在工作中，现在一切都很好，我们会很快好起来。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
Nobody interrupts him. But as soon as he's done talking and one of the onstage sheiks starts another speech, congratulating Horan for his words, the audience sheiks are standing up, screaming out that there is no security. Iraq is less safe now than ever. Electricity is completely unreliable. The sheiks onstage are telling them to be quiet. One says "Be polite. We are Arabs. We are a polite people." But the audience sheiks won't stop shouting out their complaints. One of the onstage sheiks finally says to a man in the audience who won't sit down, "Dear sir, go ahead. You're welcome to speak."
没人打断他。但当他讲完，台上一位酋长开始另一场演讲，祝贺霍兰的言论时，台下的酋长们站了起来，尖叫着说根本没有安全。伊拉克现在比以往任何时候都更不安全。电力完全不可靠。台上的酋长们叫他们安静。一个人说：“礼貌点。我们是阿拉伯人。我们是有礼貌的民族。”但台下的酋长们不会停止大喊他们的抱怨。台上的一位酋长最终对台下一个不肯坐下的男人说：“亲爱的先生，请便。欢迎发言。”
At this point, the meeting is pretty much over as an organized event. One sheik after another stands up and screams out how badly things are going under the Americans. Horan and the sheiks onstage never respond to these impromptu speeches. They just sit on the stage and watch the audience take over.
此时，这次会议作为一场有组织的活动已经基本结束了。一位接一位酋长站起来尖叫着美军统治下的事情有多糟糕。霍兰和台上的酋长们从未回应这些即兴演讲。他们只是坐在台上看着台下的人接管了一切。
[AUDIENCE SOUNDS]
[听众声音]
How did you think the meeting went? Did you feel the Americans were listening to you? Were they responsive to what you were saying?
你觉得这次会议进行得怎么样？你觉得美国人在听你们说吗？他们对你们所说的话有回应吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
I don't think they are responding to these demands.
我不认为他们正在回应这些需求。
One of the angriest sheiks in the audience is Faisal [? Rakan ?] [? Nisriz ?] al-Goud, the head of a large family in the Dulaim tribe, the biggest tribe in Iraq with 5 million members. Goud says he came to the meeting completely pro-American. He loves George Bush. But because of meetings like this one, the sheiks are divided off into those who want to declare war on the Americans immediately and moderates like him, who want to give the Americans one more month to see their true intentions before declaring war.
台下最愤怒的酋长之一是费萨尔·拉坎·尼斯里兹·阿尔-古德，杜莱姆部落一个大家族的领袖，这是伊拉克最大的部落，有500万成员。古德说他来参加会议时是完全亲美的。他爱乔治·布什。但因为像这样的会议，酋长们分成了那些想要立即向美国人宣战的人，以及像他这样想要再给美国人一个月时间看看他们真实意图再宣战的温和派。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
By then I think all heads of tribes and members of tribes will start attacking the coalition forces by every means, whether by grenades, clashing [? coast ?], anything to fight the coalition, the US presence in Iraq.
到时候我想所有部落的首领和成员都会开始以各种手段攻击联盟部队，无论是手榴弹、冲突，任何手段来对抗联盟，美国在伊拉克的存在。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
No more than one month.
不超过一个月。
Are you ready to fight in a month?
你准备好在一个月后战斗了吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语发言]
We are a united people. And we stand by each other in facing good or bad things.
我们是一个团结的民族。无论面临好事还是坏事，我们都站在一起。
It's hard to tell how serious this threat is. Things seem to get more violent each week in Iraq as people get more frustrated. Either way, it's not good. The sheiks came to a meeting that the Americans hoped would get across our message of hope, that we're in Iraq to rebuild, to help, not to stay. And Goud and the other sheiks came out of it madder than ever, talking about war.
很难说这个威胁有多严重。伊拉克的情况似乎每周都变得更加暴力，因为人们变得越来越沮丧。无论怎样，这都不好。酋长们来到一个美国人希望传递我们希望信息的会议，即我们来伊拉克是为了重建，为了帮助，而不是为了留下。而古德和其他酋长从会议中出来时比以往任何时候都更愤怒，谈论着战争。
In my last week in Baghdad, my translator, Amjad, and I had lunch with a friend of his who was telling funny stories about how, as a little boy, he actually met Saddam Hussein. Saddam used to invite kids to the palace and hand out toys in big photo ops for the newspapers to show what a great guy he was. Amjad laughed. "It's just like Bremer," he said. The head of the US operation, Paul Bremer, had just invited the press to photograph him handing out soccer balls to young people. "You know what we call Bremer?" Amjad's friend asked me. "Bremer Hussein."
在我在巴格达的最后一周，我的翻译阿姆贾德和我与他的一位朋友共进午餐，他讲了一些有趣的关于他小时候如何真的见过萨达姆·侯赛因的故事。萨达姆过去常邀请孩子们去宫殿并分发玩具，作为报纸的大型拍照机会，以展示他是一个多么伟大的人。阿姆贾德笑了。“这就像布雷默，”他说。美军行动的首脑保罗·布雷默，刚刚邀请媒体拍摄他分发足球给年轻人的照片。“你知道我们怎么叫布雷默吗？”阿姆贾德的朋友问我。“布雷默·侯赛因。”
Which brings me back to that weird rumor about Saddam and why it's so popular, the rumor that he worked with the Americans, arranged for the invasion, and now lives in the White House. For all the important differences between American rule and Saddam's government, Iraqis say they're seeing some of the same things. The country is still run by reclusive men who make decisions in private and issue their orders from behind the guarded walls of the Republican Palace.
这让我想起了关于萨达姆的那个奇怪的谣言，为什么它如此流行，那个他与美国人合作、安排了入侵、现在住在白宫的谣言。尽管美军统治与萨达姆政府之间存在所有重要的区别，但伊拉克人说他们看到了一些同样的东西。国家仍然由深居简出的人运行，他们在私下里做出决定，并从共和国宫守卫森严的墙后发布命令。
Adam Davidson is a regular contributor to our show and has recently been Marketplace 's correspondent in Baghdad.
亚当·戴维森是我们节目的定期撰稿人，最近一直是《市场》在巴格达的通讯员。
Well, our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for free or buy tapes. Or you know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times , all at audible.com.
好吧，我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买磁带。或者你可以从audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目，畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。
Alex Meyer, the teenager from the beginning of our program, is at alexmeyer.tk. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who has just one request.
节目开始时的少年亚历克斯·梅耶在alexmeyer.tk。《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他只有一个请求。
There's a little gap down by the baseboard. Bend over and close it, will you?
踢脚板那里有个小缝。弯腰把它关上，好吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。